un sujet qui me passionne parce que
parce que qui nous passionne parce que
j'ai vu tellement de choses cette
semaine sur les réseaux sociaux
donc voilà les stars ont de l'argent est
souvent le font savoir le problème c'est
que tout ça ça se passe en plein un
gilet jaune en plein moment où les
français galèrent et ça se passe mal le
footballeur franck ribéry vous le savez
l'animatrice alessandra sublet notamment
qui en ont fait les frais pendant les
vacances et de manière très très
violente
ribéry on va en parler en plus s'il
était sanctionné alors fait il est
choqué par cet étalage de l'argent est
ce que c'est un mal français
oui ou non regardez on en parle après du
cros chaîne en or des diamants des
boucles d'oreilles des montres des
bagues des lunettes des fourrures des
voitures des jets privés des temps en or
on pensait avoir tout vu dans la
catégorie bling bling et mauvais goût 7
sans compter sur ce pont vieux franck
ribéry et quelques copains footballeur
voici donc la nouvelle façon
intelligente de montrer sa thune
s'offrir une côte de boeuf en or
bravo les gars fallait la trouver celle
là certes après tout ribéry son argent
il en fait ce qu'il veut mais en ces
temps de bataille sur le pouvoir d'achat
c'est pas très finaud un site belge s'en
amuse d'ailleurs ribéry mange une
entrecôte recouverte d'or en soutien au
gilet jaune pendant que quittiez
deschamps lui le tacle sur europe 1 il
ya ce besoin de cette nouvelle
génération de 2,2 montrer mon jeu ça me
viendrait pas à l'idée de filmer ou de
lui envoyer une photo de ce que je mange
ou où je suis
mais bon et des idées pour afficher son
argent c'est pas ce qui manque
kim kardashian et sa combi de ce qu'il y
à 3000 euros robin thicke et son micro
en or beyoncé de sa adat de baseball en
dollars sans oublier la garde-robe de
meghan markle à 4 178 1000 euros alors
face à ces stars qui flambent
vous êtes choqués ou pas choquer voilà
ce que d'être choqués ou pas choquer
choqué mathieu alterman pourquoi oui
parce qu'il faut faire attention en
fonction du public qu'on a atterri béret
un public très populaire il ya des
gamins des quartiers des gens pour y
manger une entrecôte en or au delà du
bris indécent c'est complètement con
faut quand même le dire c'est pas bien
c'est pas dépenser son argent dans
quelque chose de beau d'un thé la provoc
c'est nul alors évidemment ribéry donne
beaucoup d'argent des oeuvres
humanitaires c'est vrai on le sait mais
là c'est juste il envoie un signal en
plus etc ce qui se passe en france
aujourd'hui c'est complètement con fins
et c'est débile même comme on peut y'a
personne autour de lui que les dits non
on va peut-être pas montrer ça parce que
c'est tout mais dans le mauvais goût
oui mais dans ces cas là je te dire
aussi qu'entre ricardo montre une une
bugatti veyron à un million de dollars
que tous les footballeurs manceaux en
mille euros
ces voitures de collection c'est moins
bête que mme angeline entrecôte
chacun pour soi même temps pas tous en
même temps passe hockey luc banon je
suis pas choqué parce que je trouve que
c'est autant il donne des milllions
d'euros à des associations pour les
aider il a droit de manger une donnée
non une entrecôte fait une côte de boeuf
à 400 euros
c'est de l'or s'amusant c'est faux bien
un peu gros et la fantaisie quoi va pas
tous maintenant baisser la tête
robe de bure est allumée luc luc de la
fantasy alors je voulais c'est parler
mais de la fantaisie
quand tu es à dubaï tu as la chance de
manger un chacun mange le si tu veux
mais est ce que le même jour tous les
français sont dans la rue en train de
1000 euros est-ce que c'est pas vraiment
une provocation l'air de dire ce qu'il
veut dans merde alors alors on a un choc
et 11 à 3 dont je partage ma vie c'est
je partage avec vous je vous montre la
lune est sérieux il faut bien que les
gens rêvent cependant vous crever de
faim sur un pont ou bateke des flics le
pentagone aux plus âgés les charges se
paye pour essayer d'avoir la cote pour
raison c'est ça le problème
en effet il ya un climat en ce moment un
petit peu détestable les stars elles ont
toujours flamber on a toujours vu quand
on remonte à des années
liz taylor et ses rivières de diamants
michael jackson qui faisait des caprices
invraisemblable même johnny qu'on
regrette tous avec ses bagnoles ces
motos ces maisons les stars elles sont
là pour ça le seul qui est gênant ce
moment avec ce set ce qui m'a connu en
ce moment c'est que ça crée un quelque
chose de malsain parce qu'il faut juste
un petit peu de pudeur
c'est super que les stars flambe
jusqu'en dans un climat
prérévolutionnaire connaît en ce moment
c'est qu'on se montrer avec un stack en
or ou montrer ses vacances du j'ai
compris que c'était maladroit lui fait
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on doit tous
justifiés et qu'on peut plus se
permettre de rien faire olemps faire
massacrer
on est amoureux d'une femme plus jeune
on se fait massacrer on va dubaï baïsse
fait un kif dans sa vie eh bien il se
fait massacrer tout le monde se fait
massacrer en course a tranché à cause de
quoi à cause de ce qui s'est fait
bouffer les réseaux sociaux sans vie les
gens les regardent les gens aiment ça
eux ils aiment ça car est il faut
arrêter de tout noir et après les
réseaux sociaux n'est ce pas la vraie
vie aussi mettez vous ça en tête un jour
il n'avait que franck ribéry n'est pas
un type très intelligent c'est pas un
scoop non plus quoi alors juste un
bateau avant de vous laisser parler
avant de vous laisser parler voilà ce
que tu est choquant si c'est parce que
franck ribéry a été sanctionné ensuite
par son club mais sanctionné pour ce
qu'il a répondu parce qu'il s'est fait
la tête haute avec audrey pulvar
évidemment sa réponse pour 2019
remettons les points sur les i et les
barres sur les t
commençons par les envieux les rats je
n'ai sûrement d'une capote trou et ses
classes monique et vous ai compris vos
mères vos grands-mères et même votre
arbre généalogique
bon je reconnais qu'ils avaient
peut-être il aurait pu répondre avec un
lionel enfin bon alors juste un mot de
rachel campus vie avec un footballeur
janvier au silence d'otto plus long bah
voilà ben c'est plutôt du genre à la la
baraque à frites
ouais on est plutôt cool mais de barback
aux polémiques
oui ça m'a choqué parce que je vais
marquer pas choquer je suis pas oui
enfin bref en tout cas ce qui me choque
c'est que on jette la pierre sueur sur
franck ribéry qui lui donne énormément
d'argent aux associations et qu'il ne
s'en vante pas voilà vraiment de bon
coeur et voilà il s'est fait un kiff
mais voilà ces soucis des réseaux
sociaux on ou 1000 mais j'entendais ce
qu'on ménage pas de choses c'est comme
si moi j'arrive dans la ruche casse ta
gueule de quelqu'un jeudi à côté de ça
les gars j'ai filé plein d'argent pour
les restos du coeur d'or c'est dans ce
qu'est ce qu'on fait conjuchem un
panneau sidéré sandra sublet pardon
parce qu'il risquait il reste un petit
peu de temps passeront sublet qui a
passé ses vacances à saint barth et qui
s'est fait insulter
donc voilà en france daniel en fait
c'est vrai que moi ça me choque parce
qu'il devrait justement comprendre
malheureusement vous parlez vous avais
dit le mot rêve tout à l'heure catherine
les gens n'ont même plus les moyens de
rêver c'est à dire avant chanel goma à
personne de voir ça on savait que ça
existe et légendes et maintenant elle
viendrait levé daniel ils achèteraient
pas la presse people will le magma j
aime bien rêver le dos mais justement à
main sur six marabout est ce qu'il a
fait une erreur ou pas elle est
animatrice montrer ses vacances à sa
peinture les réseaux à plein en place en
ce moment
mais catherine justin a les mots myriam
pour aller sans assumer c'est un peu
particulier quand même ses parents
libanais visage oui elle s'est fait
insulter après c'est effectivement ce
que j'ai donc qu'ils vivent qu'ils
aillent sur des îles paradisiaques qui
dépensent beaucoup d'argent c'est c'est
tant mieux pour eux c'est super on va
pas les crises beaucoup d'argent il en
profite tant mieux c'est le fait qu'ils
n'explosent qui merci beaucoup ma chérie
on a un sondage voilà donc choqué pas
choqué et a vu le petit ma chérie
ballard choqué pas choqué a quand même
comprenez vous que cela fasse polémique
non à 51% donc voilà malgré tout bas
lève encore une fois le twitter n'est
pas l'avis donc ses babouches constaté
d'insultés sur twitter que c'est l'avis
de tous les français